[Music]
on this sunday night
the galactic experience billionaire
richard branson takes off in his
own spaceship is this the dawn of space
tourism
blazing hot the worsening wildfire
situation in the u.s
plus the signs the leaders are in
election mode but what are the key
issues
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Applause]
history has been made high in the sky 86
kilometers above earth
billionaire richard branson has traveled
to the edge of space aboard his virgin
galactic
unity 22 space plane good evening and
thank you for joining us
branson was in a race with amazon
founder jeff bezos to reach for the
stars with commercial space travel
with one test flight done the dream is a
little closer to reality for these
moneyed men
though as mike delay explains the rest
of us may have to dream
a little longer if you ever wondered how
a billionaire arrives to his own space
launch
the answer is via bicycle flanked by a
pair of suvs
sir richard branson certainly knows how
to make an entrance
hours later spaceship two is in the air
release release release
eventually accelerating upwards with
three g's of force
virgin's broadcast was meant to be
glitzy welcome to space unity 22
but it turned out glitchy the audio and
video from inside the cabin didn't make
the feed
leaving the announcers to plant the flag
for virgin as the first commercial space
line
and remember the name virgin galactic
because today
space is virgin territory no doubt
fellow billionaire and amazon founder
jeff bezos will have something to say
about that
his blue origin new shepard rocket will
launch in nine days
and with an unknown person paying 28
million dollars for a seat
bezos technically has the first paying
customer
what bezos won't have is this moment
canadian astronaut chris hadfield
pinning astronaut wings
on branson's lapel ladies and gentlemen
this here is sir richard branson
astronauts
billionaire bragging rights aside
experts say there's no denying this is
the dawn of a new space age
i think the important thing here is that
uh except for you know a handful of
billionaires who could fit comfortably
in my house
the only way to get into space is to
become a professional
astronaut the history of space flight by
humans goes back 60 years now
and there's still fewer than 600 people
who've gone into space
you can now add four more to that list
including a seven-year-old adventure
seeking billionaire
hoping to inspire his grandkids to the
next generation of dreamers
if we can do this just imagine
what you can do
[Music]
mike relay global news toronto what an
amazing time in the world
well soccer fans around the world and in
canada poured into pubs and onto patios
as england battled italy for soccer
supremacy
at the european championship final
the atmosphere has been unbelievable in
montreal people spilled onto the streets
showing nothing but excitement
after italy caused a major upset winning
the final
in a penalty shootout thousands of
fired up fans crammed into wembley
stadium for the game
thousands more outside this was
england's first final in 55 years on
home
soil but italy has a long-standing
tradition of success
and proved it today here's redmond
shannon with all the reaction from
london
[Music]
10 hours before kickoff and the party
was
already well underway line-ups in true
english style outside pubs across the
country
fans buoyed by the confidence of the
sunday tabloids
and the team encouraged by prince
william
can't really believe this is happening
so exciting
and just wish you the very best of luck
you bring out the very best of england
and
we are all behind you the whole country
is behind you so um
bring it home the hype and the
anticipation is so strong because for
england
it's been so long 55 years since the
men's team has been in a major final
on that occasion they won the world cup
right here at home
at wembley stadium i think it feels
incredible we've
been waiting all my life i'm 52 years
old we're 53 today in fact
um so yeah just it's amazing amazing
it's a dream that i never thought would
ever happen
for the younger fans it's a celebration
after the drudgery of lockdown
and everything that's going on not
having the fans for so long
football being paused it's good to be
back then
wembley two-thirds full some sixty
thousand fans but due to travel
restrictions only one thousand italians
were allowed to travel to london
as kickoff approached the party started
getting out of hand
fans without tickets breaking through a
security barrier
attempting to get into the stadium these
types of scenes a scourge that has
blighted english soccer
through the decades
robin some of those people actually did
make it into the stadium but authorities
say that most of them were ejected
but everyone of course is not talking
about that right now hugely dramatic it
went to extra time
and then penalty kicks italy winning
eventually in a hugely dramatic penalty
shootout england's teenage star 19 year
old bukay osaka
from london here missed the last kick to
give italy the championship
its second euro championship england yet
to win the title
england now at least 55 years without a
men's
major soccer tournament title people
here
are absolutely devastated i can see that
the
pub patio behind me emptied oh so
quickly and police are probably
glad to see that it's raining now which
may mean some of the skirmishes we saw
earlier
in the day may not be repeated tonight
robin redman shannon in london thanks
redmond
[Applause]
well you know where the party is when in
rome
with one very happy crowd you can see
the jubilation in the streets of rome
moments after italy's big win
its first major title since 2006.
turning to british columbia where a new
wildfire prompted an evacuation order
close to a popular resort
the fire broke out last night near the
community of whitecroft it's about 10
kilometers west of sun peaks
an evacuation order was issued for 132
homes in the area
the resort itself is still operational
around bc there are more than 300
active fires nearly a quarter of them
are considered
out of control transport canada has
ordered cn
and cp rails to take steps to to prevent
fires along rail lines
that includes reducing the speed of
trains in areas where the fire risk is
extreme
and temperatures are higher than 30
degrees in bc specifically the two rail
companies are required to ensure at
least 10
fire patrols are conducted every 24
hours
in designated areas and they must remove
any combustible material along tracks
conductors are responsible for spotting
and reporting any fires along their
routes
an investigation is underway to
determine if a train may have been
responsible
for the devastating fire that ravaged
the village of linton b.c
last month during a record heat wave
wildfires and withering temperatures are
scorching the western u.s
the searing heat isn't just making fire
conditions worse
it's hindering firefighting efforts in
parts of california crews are finding
that the water when dropped from
aircraft
just evaporates before it even reaches
the ground as jennifer johnson reports
emergency orders have been put in place
up and down
the west coast tens of millions of
americans in the western part of the
country are under extreme heat warnings
as blistering temperatures break records
and wildfires explode
california's death valley and joshua
tree national park
are among the hottest places on earth
it's never been hotter
it feels like we're in an oven yeah
severe drought conditions are sparking
wildfires
72 kilometers north of lake tahoe
california's beckworth fire has doubled
in size
now burning into nevada oregon's bootleg
fire is raging out of control too
forcing evacuations the fire is
is just exploding and continuing
to grow dramatically
we are seeing you know doubling in size
of the fire
every 24 hours last month's heat wave in
the region killed more than 160 people
now washington and oregon have issued
emergency orders to protect farm workers
exposed to the high temperatures
other industries are being hard hit too
tides off of washington are at their
lowest levels in years
bringing shellfish to the surface too
soon between harmful algal blooms and
and water quality issues and the
pandemic without question
there's just a number number of things
that are starting to change the
landscape
of how we farm oysters and clams las
vegas is breaking records too
just as tourists come back after the
pandemic shut down the strip for much of
the past
year this is really hot i mean i was in
the military
qatar was hot this is hot governors in
several states are asking residents to
conserve power and water
the heat is quickly drying up typical
water sources
it wants to evaporate off of the soils
up in the mountains
off of the reservoirs this latest heat
wave comes after the u.s saw its hottest
june
on record jennifer johnson global news
washington saskatchewan has joined
alberta
in removing all clover 19 health
restrictions
there are now no limits to social
gatherings inside or
outside in saskatchewan it's no longer
mandatory to wear masks either
health officials justified the move
citing 70 percent of the population 12
and older has received at least one dose
of a covenant 19 vaccine
just over 50 percent are fully
vaccinated
in yet another sign of the times the
university of calgary is ending a once
popular program for oil and gas
engineers
the school says fewer jobs in the
industry have led to a big drop in
demand for the course
as heather yorks west explains the
energy sector is shifting away from
fossil fuels
and future engineers are trying to find
the right fit
at one time mustafa al-assadi thought
his future was an oil
originally i'm from iraq so when i came
here 2009 where
mostly in the back of my mind when i
came to calgary it was all
oil and gas but in 2016 just two years
into his career as a petroleum engineer
al-assadi was laid off the price of oil
fell dramatically in 2015
and while prices have recovered the
energy industry as a whole
is in the midst of an undeniable shift
in the heart of canada's energy sector
the university of calgary has taken note
this downturn
i think has been an extended downturn
compared to previous
cycles and this is obviously influenced
many of our students
our students want jobs when they when
they graduate it's why the university
has decided to
end its once popular bachelor of oil and
gas
engineering program certainly there's a
changing energy
landscape i would say not just in
alberta but globally there's a lot of
push
towards other forms of energy for
example hydrogen and geothermal
wind and solar and and this is happening
right here in alberta
the ufc is not alone in the city as it
shifts its programming to keep pace with
an economy in transition
last year state launched a new school
for advanced digital technology
a move intended to prepare more students
for careers in tech
after struggling to find another job as
a petroleum engineer
alasadi went back to school training now
in the ufc's new
energy engineering program i am hoping
that
that i could find a different route
trying to look into the alternative
energy and how can we
change between the fossil fuel into the
alternative energy as
as we all now committed to to do this as
the energy sector transitions
nobody wants to be left behind heather
urex west global news
calgary coming up federal leaders are
crisscrossing the country
are canadians ready for an election
prime minister justin trudeau has spent
the week crisscrossing the country
with cabinet ministers in tow and making
funding announcements
these are signs of an election and to
prepare for a summer campaign
each leader will have to make a specific
pitch the so-called
ballot question tonight david aiken
takes a look at the pitches
intended to woo voters is being fighting
for you this pandemic
that's the ballot question jug meat
sings ndp wants voters to think about
and the ndp is already running ads like
this
on social media trying to frame what
they think
is the key issue of any election we
might have this summer
i think the question is going to come
down to who's in it for me who's going
to fight for me who has
fought for me and who has delivered the
help that i need a careful definition of
the ballot question
is a key part of any election campaign
says this former key strategist
in jack leighton's campaign war rooms
when you have a clearly defined
ballot question it is much easier to
identify
the voters and the way they will behave
on election day
so it's a bit like a magic bullet it
appears that conservatives have not
centered on one single message yet but
they definitely want to attack the
trudeau government's record on
pandemic management and the vaccine
rollout let's go back to july 2019
in this slickly produced video
conservative leader aaron o'toole
argues the trudeau government
compromised national security
on covid vaccine development how did two
scientists with these ties
get approval to work at this secret
facility pollster daryl bricker though
thinks
by the end of summer voters may not be
in the mood for
that kind of pitch from the tories the
issue that the
the opposition parties have is that
people are not perceiving the current
incumbent government as being fatally
flawed as for the incumbent liberals
the only claim they can hang an early
election call on are
complaints that legislation banning
conversion therapy and
legislation regulating tech giants is
stalled
in the unelected senate unfortunately
the conservatives including members of
the conservative party in the senate
continue to show concerns about these
legislations and oppose these
legislative changes now all parties will
spend the next several weeks
fine-tuning these pitches these ballot
questions as politicians
once again travel about the country
because for a politician a
two-door summer is the perfect time to
prepare for a
late summer general election david aiken
global news
ottawa still ahead the disease that
nearly wiped out
bats and the signs the species is
bouncing back
[Music]
researchers in nova scotia are baffled
over the number of
bats they're seeing a decade ago a
fungus known as white nose syndrome
wiped out 90 percent of the province's
bats the disease spread across north
america killing millions of these winged
animals
but as ross lord explains bats appear to
be back
in trouble sir yeah it's not going to
survive
a little brown bat is forced awake by a
disease called white nose syndrome
caused by a fungus that afflicts the
mammals during hibernation
in the winter without bugs to eat the
bat's future is hopeless
15 years ago the syndrome spread from
new york state to the maritimes
quebec and ontario so the bat population
was almost basically wiped out which
makes researchers
surprised and excited by what they're
finding this summer
this year for bet seems to be a really
awesome year we've seen more bats than
we typically expect at some of the sites
we've
monitored long term researchers hope
bats are rebounding
with no long-term monitoring program for
bats it's hard to know for sure
and it's a slow recovery because they
can only have one baby called a pup
per year along with encouraging signs
there's a note of caution
this bat researcher says the disease
continues to spread west across
canada so that's the first time it's
been detected in western manitoba it's
already been in eastern manitoba
last year and that's the farthest west
it has gone
generating sympathy for bats isn't easy
i was just conducting a little
experiment trying to find out how the
devil bat does is killing
from the earliest days of motion
pictures we've been conditioned to see
them in a negative light
often as tiny monsters but for farmers
and foresters
canada's 18 species of bats are actually
free exterminators from about 3 to
56 billion are some of the latest
estimates i've seen per year
in this pest control service that bats
provide as they urge the public to help
the cause by reporting that sightings
researchers hope they'll have stronger
evidence that the bats came back
by the end of summer ross lord global
news
a seat on the galactic a quarter million
a dream come true
priceless up next the canadian who has a
ticket to ride
there's no low-cost carrier when it
comes to space travel
a seat on virgin galactic space plane
will cost a quarter million once
commercial flights begin
as joe scarpelli reports a winnipeg
doctor has her ticket
and her place in line three
two one release release release
and here it is look at that judy
anderson has been waiting
11 years for this moment it was pretty
awesome i gotta say i
i didn't expect to be as excited as i
was
i'm gonna be there but she'll have to
wait a little longer for
that moment so they're at 236 000.
the retired university of manitoba
professor holds ticket 623 to board one
of virgin galactic's commercial flights
to space
that process won't start until at least
next year
but after decades of fantasies and one
failed attempt at becoming a canadian
astronaut in the 90s
her dream is finally within reach i just
love the idea
of floating and seeing the earth from
up in space you know seeing the
curvature of the earth
seeing what she's describing costs a
pretty penny a ticket is around 250
000 u.s anderson signed up in 2010
and locked in at 200 000. she's already
made a 20
000 down payment and will have to pay
the rest in full
about three months before her flight we
have over half
in u.s dollars i'll eat macaroni and
cheese
for the rest of my life virgin galactic
is offering two astronaut hopefuls a
chance to win a spot on one of the first
flights
if enough people all over the world
participate it just means we can just
keep on you know the charity can keep on
uh
doing tickets for people so it's a
lovely sort of self-propelling
way of just trying to get lots of people
who couldn't have otherwise afforded to
go to space to go to space
a free ticket might be the only way to
get anderson's husband on board
half a million dollars is a pretty
expensive holiday
but no i don't really feel that much of
a
of a desire to go his loss says his wife
i'm so looking forward to it especially
after this morning
joe scarpelli global news winnipeg
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is north bay ontario
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow until then
good night
[Music]
you